et on va plus loin avec à côté Marc SEMO
collaborateur journal Le Monde bonjour
Marc bonjour et Go Thierry winsky
Chronica international à France 24 la
Turquie va-t-elle mener une médiation
dans la guerre que mène Moscou en
Ukraine le Kremlin la suggéré hier en
amont de la rencontre qui avait lieu cet
après-midi entre Vladimir Poutine et
Redjep a hyper Dean à astrada sauf
qu'aujourd'hui il n'en a plus été
question du moins pas ouvertement Marx
ces mots comment vous l'expliquez
d'abord mener une médiation et ouvrir
aujourd'hui un dialogue direct entre la
vieille mère Poutine et
universelinski ça tient de l'impossible
mais Moscou c'est un peu mouillé hier
quand même mouillé
erdan rêve de faire ça d'une certaine
façon rejetée hyper De Haan réussi là où
Macron a quand même échoué donc d'où
parfois quelques réactions presque de
jalousie de la part du président
français on peut pas laisser ça
seulement à la Turquie le fait de parler
à Poutine bon alors ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que R2 a Nagi dans l'espace que
lui laisse Vladimir Poutine la Turquie
joue un rôle très ambigu d'équilibre il
a de l'Ukraine ils ont bloqué des
détroits en appliquant le détroit de
Montreux les accords de Montreux c'était
fondamental ils disent ils ont été les
premiers à livrer des drones au début
ont eu et continue d'ailleurs mais ont
eu un rôle essentiel au début mais en
même temps n'ont pas pris de sanctions
contre la Russie il y a énormément de
Russes qui arrivent en Turquie donc ils
sont cette espèce de jeu de subtil
équilibre qui d'ailleurs rappelle celui
de la Turquie pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale qui est resté entre les deux et
qui finalement est rentré en guerre aux
côtés des Alliés genre deux mois ou
trois mois je me souviens plus avant la
fin de la guerre donc
erdouane a réussi des choses il peut
réussir peut-être à malgré tout parce
qu'on est dans une situation il y a
cette musique
de fond qui monte pourquoi ne pas
commencer à parler de cesser le feu pour
offrir à la Russie une porte de sortie
le Premier ministre indien qui le
propose la Chine n'ont pas en parle donc
il y a cette espèce de musique de fond
et c'est effectivement le grand des
Russes aujourd'hui bon il continue à
perdre du terrain pour le moment
militairement ils n'ont aucun moyen de
renverser la situation donc ceux qui ont
intérêt à vaccer le feu à on est loin
d'un accord de paix c'est les Russes
évidemment pour des raisons
diamétralement opposées les
Ukrainiens n'ont aucune raison de le
faire maintenant alors rappelons
effectivement Gauthier la Turquie a voté
à la résolution hier à l'Assemblée
générale de l'ONU condamnant la
l'annexion à des régions ukrainiennes
par Moscou dans ces conditions quel rôle
peut jouer à la jet à hyper douane
on est c'est pas abstenu la Turquie non
non on est en présence d'un personnage
qui n'est jamais aussi à l'aise que
quand il fait le grand écart parce que
je pense que voilà on va pas faire de la
psychologie de bazar mais que ça flotte
profondément son narcissisme la Turquie
et ben oui je l'ai pas fait exprès de
corriger non
ce qui ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que
d'une part il y a des choses qui
lientoan aboutit c'est la Syrie c'est le
fait que finalement il est obligé de
Poutine dans un certain nombre de cas de
figure qu'on va pas rappeler ici parce
que ça serait trop long mais que dans le
même temps il est bien sûr dans le temps
et qu'il a finalement une oreille de
ceux qui lui disent si pour une fois je
dois ne pouvait jouer un rôle
intéressant parce qu'on se souvient de
ce qui s'est passé avec les migrants et
Redouane jouant le rôle pardonnez-moi
l'expression mais elle est à des seins
grossière d'un bassin de rétention pour
les migrants et là finalement quand vous
écoutez par exemple
erdouane ou ministre jovo chelou qui dit
il faut se dépêcher de faire une au
moins semblant de négociation pour un
cesser le feu mais effectivement ce que
dit Marx et moi est tout à fait juste
qui préconise ce genre de choses ce qui
soutiennent Moscou en disant plus on se
dépêche moins les choses seront
catastrophiques pour Moscou et c'est
dans ce sens-là qu'on peut être
scandalisé c'est que de ce si vous
voulez pour les esprits faibles c'est
une manière de cracher sur les morts
Ukrainiens c'est une manière de cracher
sur la résistance ukrainienne et sur les
dissidents russes c'est à dire passons
par pertes et profits cette affaire
essayons d'en sortir le mieux possible
aux yeux de la Russie pour que Poutine
ne perde pas la face et puis après on
dira tout ça c'était c'était
profondément gênant on l'a plus à s'en
préoccuper en plus c'est un mouvement de
fond c'est là on le voit maintenant ça a
commencé un peu cet été ça se concrétise
maintenant avec donc cette tentative de
rédempterne de jouer les médiateur mais
ça va monter en puissance on peut
prendre le pari jusqu'au G20 les pays du
G20 qui se réunissent en Indonésie
d'abord ils ont invité Poutine ce qui au
grand dam des Américains qui étaient
foudrages et des Occidentaux oui parce
qu'ils sont beaucoup moins marqués que
le G7 pour le coup vous avez déjà
majorité des pays du G20 et qui est
tiède se sont abstenus team la Chine
l'Inde Afrique du Sud Afrique du Sud
voilà donc tous ces pays là
sont dans cette logique mais cette
histoire est en train de de tout
perturber sa perturbe le commerce
mondial l'Afrique mais risque la famille
non yes cette espèce de mouvement de
fond qui s'autoproclame de ces pays qui
s'autoproclame les représentants d'un
Sud global qui appelle à trouver un
accord donc tout ça donc évident
ou de chance qu'on arrive à un accord la
vie mais il y aura des premiers jalons
qui vont être posés et ça va monter en
puissance jusqu'en novembre avec cette
réunion du G20 où on ne peut rien
exclure et si vous voulez ce qui va
devenir difficile c'est qu'effectivement
la question qui risque de se poser c'est
est-ce que c'est la paix ou la victoire
voilà c'est le la Turquie n'a pas voté
l'annexion des
des Castres
par ailleurs y compris à Stana le
président kazakhla ou a lieu la
rencontre de 27 pays aussi la rencontre
entre Poutine et hardwan non plus
une écrasante majorité de pays dans le
monde sont 43 l'ONU peut plus qui sont
obtenus qui refusent de reconnaître
cette annexion donc tout va tourner un
peu autour de ça Gauthier 3 3 questions
une finalement une médiation qui ne dit
pas son nom Moscou ya l'avait annoncé
voilà
erdouane ne consomme même pas finalement
à l'annoncer est-ce que ça n'en dit pas
long là aussi sur l'affaiblissement
relatif de la de la Russie qui en est
aujourd'hui à se reposer effectivement
sur ces sur ces pays combien de temps
eux vont-ils continuer une certaine
manière à soutenir en tout cas à
maintenir la neutralité dans cette
affaire donc la Russie ne finit pas par
obéir est-ce que ça n'en dit pas lancer
sur l'évolution finalement du rapport de
force depuis le début de cette guerre on
voit aujourd'hui la Russie finalement
tributaire de ces états tout à fait
c'est ce que disait Marc il y a quelques
minutes c'est cette espèce de Sud
globale qui a une aspiration finalement
à recréer ce qu'on était les non alignés
et ce qu'on était les non alignés
c'était pas admettre c'était pas se
coucher devant des impérialismes tout du
moins a priori or là vous vous apercevez
qu'un certain nombre de Non Alignés
notamment en Afrique son pied point lié
par une forme d'infirmité politique par
exemple à ne pas avoir développé des
céréales ou le blé pour pouvoir être
dépendant des livraisons
russes qui sont finalement oui comme
vous disiez tout à l'heure qu'ils ont
vont s'impatienter de ce que produit
cette guerre et dans ce sens-là les gros
si on peut dire l'Inde
bon ça pourrait être le Brésil s'il y
avait qui se passe en ce moment au
Brésil mais vont avoir à coeur d'essayer
de récupérer cette intention du Sud
global cette intention dite non alignée
et là il y a finalement un enjeu de oui
de captation de préemption de cette dire
tendance c'est bien large c'est bien
trop large non alignés je dirais pas non
plus pour les raisons que j'ai expliqué
mais la volonté d'apparaître comme un
acteur indépendant en tout cas Emmanuel
Macron leur déni le rôle de non-aligné
comme ils l'ont dit à l'Assemblée
Générale bien sûr
n'ont jamais été un alignés
c'est une prétention mais qui qui
aujourd'hui est encore plus clair dans
son incapacité à ne pas céder aux
impérialisme en revanche et c'est leur
force
c'est quoi l'alternative parce
qu'effectivement dire bon voilà cette
paix serait une paix injuste antérinant
les atrocités qui ont été faites les
élections territoriales etc donc
alternative c'est de continuer la guerre
jusqu'à la victoire mais c'est quoi la
victoire est-ce que c'est revenir aux
frontières d'avant le 24 février est-ce
que c'est récupéré l'intégrale du
dumbass est-ce que c'est c'est surtout
la question la plus explosive la plus
cruciale celle de la Crimée alors en off
de ces offres de ce-off dont les
diplomaties les chancelles occidentales
on ne réfléchit un scénario ou le statut
de la Crimée serait gelé pour 10 ans
ensuite on en parle un espèce de nouveau
Kosovo le problème de la Crimée c'est
compliqué parce que ça a été la première
annexion il a fait la Russie la première
annexion d'un territoire par la force en
Europe depuis 1945
c'est une annexion qui a été faite après
ce qu'on appelait des petits hommes
verts donc été deux faites une
occupation militaire
voulu par Moscou mais en même temps
l'écrasante majorité de la population de
la Crimée mais elle parle les Tatars
héritiers de
l'époque mongole qui était musulman et
qui regardait vers la Turquie
traditionnellement et qui ouvert
l'Ukraine était prorus si on avait fait
un vrai référendum et pas à référendum
farce totalement verrouillé par Moscou
bon bah globalement au lieu d'avoir 90%,
il y aurait eu 60% mais ça fait aucun
doute donc la question de la Crimée va
se poser inévitablement parce que c'est
un symbole pour Poutine et parce que là
la population
ne va pas du tout accueillir
l'armée ukrainienne
la frontière de la Crimée en libérateur
les limites au retour aux frontières de
91 c'est ce que vous nous dites
si vous voulez réagir Gautier sinon il y
a effectivement j'ai juste avant de
passer au sujet suivant quand même
beaucoup plus prosaïque mais enfin ça
compte tout de même la Russie qui aurait
proposé à la Turquie de créer un hub
gasié pour exporter le gaz russe vers
l'Europe alors comment vous voyez cette
proposition qui semble un peu curieuse
dans la mesure où l'Europe aujourd'hui
n'est plus officiellement demandeuse il
y a tout de même le risque de diviser
peut-être l'Europe certains états
seraient prêt à y aller vous l'Allemagne
a refusé hier nos stream 2 qui
d'ailleurs n'est pas en activité de se
voir délivrer du gaz russe comme le
proposait Poutine par ce biais alors
tout à fait il y a deux choses vous vous
souvenez de ce discours de Poutine donc
de récemment ou tout d'un coup il a eu
l'air d'avoir pour l'Europe les yeux de
de Chimay de rodrique pour Chimène
c'est-à-dire que il disait à l'Europe
écouter vous on peut s'entendre avec
vous il y a eu une tentative là aussi de
captation bon pourquoi c'est que
l'Allemagne vous donniez l'exemple de
l'Allemagne il est tout à fait parlant
l'Allemagne dit d'ailleurs ça a été ce
que dit schols qui lui prétendait avoir
raison depuis longtemps en disant je
sais que Poutine va procéder de la sorte
non il y en a un qui a été défend
là-dessus si je taille Mayer le
président qui a dit oui je me suis
complètement planté j'ai cru que par le
dialogue et par le commerce on y
arriverait avec Poutine c'était
totalement faux donc là aujourd'hui même
avec les difficultés auxquelles
l'Allemagne auquel l'Allemagne s'expose
on les reprendra plus là-dessus mais ce
qu'on doit comprendre à travers ça de
Poutine c'est une scie une difficulté à
trouver une forme de financement les
déboucher pour s'engage et des débouchés
je vous avais parlé je crois récemment
de ce qui avait été observé les services
finlandais qui avait vu des énormes
nuages qui correspondaient à ce qu'on
appelle du torchage c'est-à-dire ce que
fait un pays ou une organisation quelle
qu'elle soit quand elle ne trouve pas
preneur et donc elle est obligée de
brûler des stocks dans le alors l'aspect
écologique de la chose c'est la preuve
d'une certaine oui faiblesse mais en
désarroi putin qui qui en deux jours
fait deux propositions pour permettre
finalement aux Européens de continuer à
consommer du gaz russe après que les
gazoduc est endommagé c'est la réalité
des rapports de force ensuite le le
problème c'est qu'est-ce qui se passe
après c'est-à-dire
est-ce que la Russie aurait été
suffisamment étrié et bon
restera
relativement
où est-ce que la Russie pensera avec
Poutine alors Poutine n'est pas
éternelle mais à une revanche et donc
c'est là-dessus que se pose la vraie
question qui est va être le vrai
casse-tête de l'après qui sera le vrai
casse-tête d'ailleurs de toutes
négociation sur le statut de l'Ukraine
qui sont les garanties que l'on peut
donner à l'Ukraine il ne faut pas
oublier que l'Ukraine en 94 en échange
de l'abandon de son arsenal nucléaire
avait été reconnu notamment par la
Russie avec les États-Unis aussi dans
ces frontières dans l'intégralité des
frontières on a vu ce qu'il en était
donc quel est le garantit on peut on
peut lui donner bon la rentrée dans
l'OTAN c'est un peu difficile mais de
fait l'idée c'est de lui donner toutes
les garanties de comme si elle était
dans l'OTAN sans que formellement elle
rentre dans le temps la Russie qui a
maintes fois et ça concerne bien sûr le
temps menacé à l'Ukraine et les
Occidentaux d'employés tous les moyens
militaires à disposition y compris
nucléaire que ferait la France dans ce
cas de figure et bien dans l'hypothèse
d'une frappe nucléaire tactique
c'est-à-dire d'une ampleur limitée et
sur le champ de bataille écoutez la
réponse qui a fait Emmanuel Macron hier
chez nos confrères de France 2
la France a une doctrine nucléaire je le
disais et notre doctrine repose sur ce
qu'on appelle les intérêts fondamentaux
de la nation et ils sont définis de
manière très claire et donc ce n'est pas
du tout ça qui serait en cause il y
avait
par exemple une attaque balistique
nucléaire en Ukraine ou dans la région
par contre ça n'appellerait pas une
réponse nucléaire
conventionnelle d'évidence et ça n'est
pas notre doctrine aujourd'hui je le dis
nous avons un cadre pour ce qui nous
concerne mais ce serait une
responsabilité historique de la part de
la Russie et c'est ça ce que je veux
dire et qu'en tant que puissance dotée
la Russie à cette responsabilités
et Vladimir Poutine le C
max et vous avez été comme plusieurs
commentateurs heurtés par ces
déclarations j'ai été surpris parce que
c'est assez maladroit alors d'abord dans
les mots
la doctrine nucléaire française on ne
parle pas d'intérêt fondamentaux on
parle d'intérêt vitaux de me dire c'est
plus ou moins la même chose ensuite ce
qui est fondamental c'est que dans ce
cas là c'est que les intérêts vitaux ne
sont pas définis clairement c'est la
base si vous voulez la base même de la
dissuasion puisque c'est une espèce de
bluff réciproque c'est
l'ambiguïté or là ce qui est terrible
c'est que ce que dit Emmanuel Macron
c'est plus ou moins de ce qui est
plausible Biden il y a quelques mois bah
disait exactement la même chose sauf les
renseignes toujours plus menaçant dire
si l'emploi l'harmonucléaire même
tactique il faut rappeler que à l'aune
des armes nucléaires d'aujourd'hui
Hiroshima c'est une arme tactique et que
la réaction serait non nucléaire même si
elle serait terrible c'est très ballot
on dit dans ces cas-là notre réaction
sera à la hauteur de la violation de ce
tabou et de toutes les règles que
représente l'emploi d'une telle arme et
il a renchéri d'ailleurs sur Twitter
Emmanuel Macron d'abolda on a comme
disent les anglophones en disant la
France ne veut pas d'une guerre mondiale
sur la question du nucléaire aussi
surtout j'ai envie de dire Gauthier on
sort de l'ambiguïté qu'à son détriment
de l'arme nucléaire oui et du pays donc
on prétend défendre les intérêts oui
alors voilà moi je me demande si
l'attitude de Macron c'est pas justement
une une assertion à visée interne pour
dire vous voyez moi je suis pas comme
les autres qui sont pour aller au clash
et puis surtout aussi peut-être dégager
à nouveau cette chose qui lui plaît tant
c'est-à-dire l'idée qu'il y a entre lui
et Poutine une voix spéciale et
privilégiée parce qu'évidemment que
cette déclaration elle a été présentée à
Poutine est-ce que ça suffit je pense
que Macron s'imagine beaucoup de choses
je sais par exemple que tout ce qui est
du côté des des lieux de pouvoir en
Russie vous savez qu'il y a un verbe
macronet qui a été créé créé et qui veut
dire en gros c'est glander et quand on a
le temps on appelle Poutine non mais je
vous promets que c'est ça donc est-ce
que Poutine peut prendre au sérieux ce
genre de saut chose je n'en suis pas
certain et je pense qu'effectivement les
conséquences sont graves dans la mesure
où ça brouille et la perturbe le concept
de dissuasion pour des résultats qui en
dehors peut-être de l'ego d'Emmanuel
Macron ne sont vraiment pas garantis je
pense que plus d'ailleurs c'est un
véritable message politique c'est bon
c'est plutôt un préparation de la chose
parce qu'effectivement quand on parle de
ces choses-là il faut pas en parler
d'ailleurs au début il a été parfait
parce que c'est effectivement on en
pense
dans ce genre de choses chaque mot est
pesé au trébuchet c'est une grammaire
extrêmement précise avec des règles
voilà donc voilà et là on sent que ça a
été un peu à sa décharge on peut dire
que rien Poutine lui depuis longtemps à
ami a mis la grammaire à la poubelle et
on peut à tort et à travers le terme de
nucléaire oui et non parce que si vous
regardez attentivement ce que dit
Vladimir Poutine
il est en réalité très prudent il parle
de de choses qu'on a de d'armes dans des
moyens conséquences qu'on n'a jamais vu
et tout mais Poutine parle peu
explicitement du nucléaire lui il
respecte cette grammaire en revanche il
laisse c'est second couteau qui a dit
Rohff et autres sinistresbir dire il
faut raser l'ombre Paris Washington mais
lui regardez relisez attentivement il
respecte un peu les
merci beaucoup Marc c'est moi d'avoir
été avec nous merci gauthierry vinski
c'était on va plus loin on se retrouve
dans 2 minutes 30 pour un nouveau
journal